acting is a profession that requires a
lot of versatility and a willingness to
test boundaries often this bravery pays
off with a critically acclaimed
performance this lauded four years or
even becomes cinematic history sometimes
however it results in a complete
nightmare for everyone involved Ellen
page's bad jerk are you honestly and
truly going to prom with Katrina de
Voort hi he just said that you were
gonna go with her Juno was a critical
darling upon its release in 2007 but
actress Ellen Page thinks the indie
comedy has one really big flaw and we're
not talking about that hamburger fire or
the overly stylized dialogue the old man
look I just drank my weight in Sunny D
and I gotta go pronto
the actress regrets Juno's joke about
potentially naming her baby Madison
isn't that like a little gay Paige told
bustled that the joke didn't register
with her at the time but now that she's
older she really wishes it hadn't
happened it's worth noting that Paige
came out as gay in 2014 and she's become
a vocal advocate for LGBTQ rights in
fact when Paige performed a staged
reading of Juno for Planned Parenthood
in 2017
she skipped that line entirely Denzel
Washington is all wet based on the 1980s
TV show of the same name the equalizer
stars Denzel Washington as Robert McCall
a widower who works at a hardware store
when he's not busy killing bad guys in
the film's climax McCall Lewis some
murderous Russian gangsters to his place
of employment where an explosion sets of
the store sprinkler system
[Music]
looks boss fried well Washington told
cinema blend he quickly got real tired
of being so damn wet but by that third
day at night after a 13 hour day I
disagree it still looks pretty boss
daughter Margot Robbie gets messy
[Music]
actress Mogga Roby had a pretty bad time
making Suicide Squad first of all her
character Harley Quinn wore skimpy
outfits that made her feel
self-conscious you're welcome and she
kept accidentally poking herself with
her spiky gold bangles Harley Quinn nice
to meet you
but when the Washington Post asked
Robbie what scene was him least favorite
she had an answer at the ready she
absolutely hated filming that scene
where Quinn throws herself into a vat of
white goose Robbie says she was utterly
repulsed because the nasty stuff kept
getting into her ears and nose I
couldn't breathe and I tried to open my
eyes and it would glaze over my eyeballs
and I could only see why it was horrible
Chris Hemsworth shirts and skins actor
Chris Hemsworth isn't too thrilled about
undressing on screen these days he was
perfectly fine being shirtless in the
first thought film but increasingly got
annoyed at those gratuitous scenes
starring his abs when thought the dark
world's rolled around director Joss
Whedon insists that he stripped down
after a big battle sequence speaking
with mtv news Hemsworth admitted he was
hesitant so ahead he said Chris Katie
showed up and I said well I don't know
you know what's the why what are we
doing it the issue came up again during
thor ragnarok and the shirt came off
again
Hemsworth told Access Hollywood he was
relieved he could keep his shirt on
during the fifth Thor film but director
Tycho ytt felt the film needed some eye
candy and then talked him midway through
the shooting come up and said I think we
need to put some bums on seats I think
we need to get the shirt off I was like
no I bet I want to say that they did
their Josh Brolin god-killer
[Music]
it's fun playing the biggest bad guy in
the universe just ask josh brolin he
crushed it astonish in Avengers infinity
war and he reportedly really enjoyed
tearing the Hulk a new one
but Brolin says he wasn't altogether
pleased about having to kill Loki
[Music]
according to Brolin actor Tom Hiddleston
was obsessed with getting Loki's last
seen just right so filming became quite
the bittersweet bummer Brolin told USA
Today tom was so vulnerable at that
moment so choked him out wasn't the most
fun thing I ever done
is it possible Loki will somehow be
resurrected much like a certain game of
Thrones character before him Kurt
Russell's hateful faith I don't feel so
good
directed by Quentin Tarantino the
hateful eight was a lightning rod for
hot takes and angry opinions but music
lovers probably had the best reason to
hate the film especially since Kurt
Russell destroyed a guitar that turned
out to be a priceless antique Russell
thought the guitar was a prop but it was
actually an instrument from the 1860s
and worth over 40 thousand dollars the
incident really shook up Lee as she'd
fallen in love with the antique and
Russell was devastated by what he'd done
I'm already regretting this speaking to
billboard Lee explained that Russell
felt terrible when he discovered his
mistake when he found out he's eyes
literally welled up it ended up being
great for the same but very sad for the
guitar and for my guitar teacher and for
me Zoe deutsches pizza program it's read
that a romantic comedy comes along and
breathes new life into the genre but
when set it up hit Netflix critics were
delighted by the tale of two employees
trying to get their bosses to hook up
starring Zoe Deutsch and Glenn pal the
film takes our predictable turn when the
true matchmakers fall in love themselves
in the film's most celebrated scene the
two co-workers share a late night pizza
which sparks their romance this is the
best you ever had
[Music]
unfortunately for Deutsch filming the
same wasn't exactly romantic that's
because she devoured four entire pies
while shooting that scene and threw up
halfway through the shoot and then she
had to get very close to Glenn pal in
order to finish the shoot she told hello
giggles I think he looks at me in a very
different light Fifty Shades of gross
critics weren't the only ones who found
Fifty Shades of Grey alarmingly unsexy
based on the runaway bestseller book of
the same name the 2015 film stars Jamie
Dornan as the snootiest sadist ever and
Dakota Johnson as his willing slave I
need you to show me what you want to do
to me punish me show me how bad it can
be
unfortunately filming all those bondage
domination and torture scenes could be
pretty bad Johnson spent hours tied up
blindfolded and pretending to be struck
by a whip
she told Time magazine it's really hot
not in a steamy sexual way it's just
sweaty and it's not very comfortable she
said the sex scenes were so taxing she
started thinking okay let's just get
this over with
coincidentally that's exactly what we
were thinking halfway through Fifty
Shades of Grey
[Music]